Il y a une quinzaine d'années, j'ai rendu visite à un ami à Hong Kong.
Et, à l'époque, j'étais très superstitieux.
Du coup, au moment d'atterrir - c'était encore à l'ancien aéroport d'Hong Kong
Kai Tak, qui était en plein milieu de la ville -
je me suis dit : si je vois quelque chose de bien, je vais passer un super moment ici,
pendant les deux semaines à venir. Et si je vois quelque chose de négatif, je vais être malheureux.
L'avion a atterri entre les immeubles
et s'est finalement arrêté en face de ce petit panneau d'affichage.
(Rires)
Et de fait, je suis allé voir des boîtes de design
à Hong Kong pendant mon séjour
et il se trouve que -
j'étais juste allé voir ce qu'ils faisaient à Hong Kong.
Mais en fait, je suis reparti avec une super offre d'emploi.
Je suis rentré en Autriche, j'ai fait mes valises,
et, une semaine plus tard, j'étais à nouveau en route pour Hong Kong
toujours plein de superstitions et en train de me dire : Bon, si ce panneau d'affichage "Gagnant" est toujours là,
je vais vraiment m'amuser en travaillant ici.
(Rires)
Mais s'il a été enlevé, ça va être vraiment déprimant et stressant.
Il se trouve que, non seulement, le panneau était toujours là,
mais en plus, ils avaient mis celui-là juste à côté.
(Rires)
Mais d'un autre côté, ça m'a aussi appris jusqu'où la superstition pouvait mener
parce que j'ai vraiment vécu une période horrible à Hong Kong.
(Rires)
Néanmoins, j'ai réellement eu de vrais moments de bonheur dans ma vie -
des moments de - je pense, ce que la brochure de la conférence décrit comme
des moments à couper le souffle.
Et comme j'adore faire des listes, j'ai fait la liste de tous ces moments.
(Rires)
Bon, vous n'avez pas à prendre la peine de les lire
et je ne vais pas les lire pour vous.
Je sais que c'est incroyablement ennuyeux d'entendre parler du bonheur des autres.
(Rires)
Ce que j'ai fait, en revanche, c'est que j'ai considéré ces moments du point de vue du design
et j'ai simplement laissé de côté tous ceux qui n'avaient rien à voir avec le design.
Et, de manière très surprenante, plus de la moitié d'entre eux avait, en fait, quelque chose à voir avec le design.
Il y a donc, bien sûr, deux possibilités.
Il y en a une où on se place du point du vue du consommateur -
où j'ai été heureux en faisant l'expérience du desgin.
Je vais vous donner juste un exemple. Je venais d'avoir mon premier Walkman.
C'était en 1983.
Mon frère avait cette super moto Yamaha
qu'il était prêt à me prêter autant que je voulais.
et l'album Synchronicity de The Police,
venait juste de sortir, en cassette,
et le port du casque n'était pas obligatoire dans la ville de Bregenz où j'habitais.
On pouvait donc rouler dans la montagne
en écoutant à plein volume The Police sur son nouveau Walkman Sony.
(Rires)
Et je m'en souviens comme d'un pur moment de bonheur.
Comme vous pouvez bien sûr le voir, c'est lié au fait que
au moins deux des composantes sont des objets de design.
Et, vous voyez, il y a une échelle de bonheur quand on parle de design,
mais l'épisode de la moto serait à coup sûr
situé quelque part - juste entre la joie et la félicité.
Maintenant, il y a cet autre aspect, le point de vue du designer -
vous êtes heureux quand vous êtes précisément en train de le faire.
Une façon de voir dans quel état sont les designers heureux lorsqu'ils sont en train de créer pourrait être de
regarder les photos des auteurs sur la quatrième de couverture de leur monographie.
(Rires)
Selon cette méthode, les Australiens et les Japonais
tout comme les Mexicains
sont très heureux.
(Rires)
Alors que, d'une certaine façon, les Espagnols
et, il me semble, tout particulièrement les Suisses
(Rires)
ne s'en sortent pas aussi bien.
En novembre dernier a été inauguré à Tokyo un musée, le musée Mori,
qui est dans un gratte-ciel, au 56e étage.
Et leur exposition inaugurale s'appelait "Bonheur".
Très enthousiaste, j'y suis allé, pour la voir, parce que -
bon aussi parce que j'avais en tête la conférence d'aujourd'hui.
et de manière très intéressante, ils ont structuré l'exposition selon quatre espaces différents.
Dans "Arcadia", ils montraient ce genre de choses, de la période Edo -
cent façons différentes d'écrire "bonheur".
Il y avait aussi cette pomme de Yoko Ono - celle qui plus tard,
comme vous savez, est devenue l'emblème des Beatles.
Dans "Nirvana", ils montraient ce tableau de Constable.
et il y avait une... théorie intéressante à propos de l'abstraction.
C'est un champ bleu - en fait, un tableau de Yves Klein
et la théorie, c'est que si vous rendez une image abstraite, eh bien en fait,
c'est autant de place que vous ouvrez à l'irreprésentable -
et par conséquent, vous êtes alors capable d'impliquer d'avantage le spectateur.
Ensuite, dans "Désir", ils montraient ces tableaux de Sunsho -
qui datent aussi de la période Edo - c'est de l'encre sur soie.
Et, pour finir, dans "Harmonie", il y avait ces mandala tibétains du 13e siècle.
Maintenant, ce que j'ai retenu de l'exposition, c'est que,
peut-être à l'exception des mandala,
la plupart des oeuvres portaient en fait sur la visualisation du bonheur,
et non sur le bonheur lui-même.
Et je me suis senti un petit peu lésé, parce que la visualisation -
c'est quelque chose de vraiment facile à faire.
Dans mon studio, par exemple, c'est ce qu'on fait tout le temps.
Voici un livre
Un chien heureux - et vous enlevez ça, ça devient un chien agressif.
Là, c'est un David Byrne heureux, et voici un David Byrne en colère.
Ou un poster de jazz avec un visage heureux, et là, un visage plus agressif.
Vous voyez, ça n'est pas très difficile à réaliser.
C'en est au point que, dans le monde de la pub,
ou dans l'industrie du cinéma, l'idée d'"heureux" a une réputation si mauvaise que
si vous voulez vraiment faire quelque chose sur le sujet,
tout en ayant l'air authentique, vous êtes quasiment obligé
de le faire avec un point de vue cynique.
Voici, par exemple, une affiche de cinéma.
Ou, ce qu'on a fait, il y a quelques semaines, c'est créer un coffret pour les Talking Heads,
où le bonheur tel qu'il apparaît sur la couverture, présente aussi un côté très sombre.
Ce qui est beaucoup beaucoup plus difficile, c'est que le design puisse réellement évoquer le bonheur,
et je vais vous montrer trois manifestations qui ont précisément cet effet sur moi.
Celui-ci est une campagne faite par un jeune artiste new-yorkais, qui se surnomme lui-même Vrai.
Toute personne qui a pris le métro à New York
connaît ces signes, n'est-ce pas ?
Vrai a produit sa propre version de ces signes.
Tous les mercredis, il retrouvait une vingtaine d'amis à une station de métro donnée.
Ils se répartissaient les différentes lignes de métro et ajoutaient leur version.
(Rires)
En voici une.
Maintenant, la façon dont ça marche, dans le métro, c'est que personne ne regarde jamais vraiment ces signes.
Vous
(Rires)
vous vous ennuyez vraiment dans le métro, et vous fixez plus ou moins votre regard sur quelque chose.
Et ça vous prend un petit peu de temps avant de vraiment
réaliser que ça dit quelque chose différent de ce que ça dit normalement.
(Rires)
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que, du moins pour moi, c'est à cause de ça que ça me rend heureux.
Ce qui se passe, c'est que Vrai est un véritable philanthrope.
Il ne voulait pas qu'un de ses amis soit arrêté.
Donc il a donné à chacun une fausse carte de volontaire.
(Rires)
et aussi cette fausse lettre de l'autorité des transports métropolitains -
qui prétendait, en quelque sorte, qu'il s'agissait d'un projet artistique,
financé par l'autorité des transports métropolitains.
(Rires)
Voici un autre projet new-yorkais.
A P.S. 1 - c'est une sculpture qui consiste en fait en une pièce carrée
faite par James Turrell, et qui a un plafond coulissant.
Le plafond s'ouvre chaque jour au crépuscule et à l'aube.
Vous ne voyez pas l'horizon.
Vous êtes juste dedans, et vous regardez les changements incroyablement subtils de la couleur du ciel.
Et vraiment, cette pièce vaut le coup d'oeil.
Le comportement des gens change quand ils vont dedans.
Ce qui est sûr aussi, c'est que je n'ai plus regardé le ciel de la même façon
après avoir passé une heure là dedans.
Bien sûr, il y a beaucoup d'autres projets que les trois que je vous montre ici.
Je dirais que, indéniablement, regarder "Nuage", de Vik Muniz,
il y a quelques années à Manhattan, est quelque chose qui, très certainement, m'a rendu heureux.
Mais le dernier projet que je voudrais vous présenter vient, à nouveau, d'un jeune designer new yorkais.
Il est originaire de Corée.
Et il a entrepris de faire imprimer 55 000 bulles -
des autocollants représentant des bulles vides, des grandes et des petites.
et il s'est promené dans New York, et a juste collé les bulles, telles qu'elles étaient, vides, sur les affiches.
(Rires)
Et d'autres gens passent et les remplissent.
Celle-ci dit : "Laissez-moi mourir en paix."
(Rires)
Je pense que
pour moi, le plus surprenant, c'est que les messages étaient vraiment très bons.
Celle-ci, sur l'affiche d'un musicien, dit :
"J'ai peur que mon CD ne se vende pas à plus de 200 000 exemplaires.
Et que, du coup, les frais d'investissement
de mon label soient perdus.
A la suite de quoi, mon contrat sera annulé,
et je n'aurai plus qu'à recommencer à faire des reprises de Journey sur Bleecker Street.
(Rires)
Je pense que la raison pour laquelle ça marche si bien est que chaque personne impliquée est gagnante.
Jee a son projet ;
le public a un environnement plus humain ;
des publics différents ont un lieu d'expression,
et les publicitaires ont enfin des gens qui regardent leurs pubs.
(Rires)
Bien. Naturellement, il y avait une question que j'ai eue en tête pendant un moment :
Est-ce qu'il est possible que je fasse davantage les choses que j'aime faire quand je fais du design
et moins celles que je n'aime pas faire ?
Ce qui m'a ramené à ma passion des listes -
simplement, donc, pour voir ce que, vraiment, j'aime dans mon travail.
L'une de ces choses est : juste travailler sans pression.
Puis : travailler en étant concentré, sans être exténué.
Ou bien, comme Nancy l'a dit juste avant, vraiment se plonger dedans.
Essayer de ne pas être coincé à faire toujours la même chose -
ou essayer de ne pas être coincé derrière l'ordinateur toute la journée.
Ce qui est lié à : sortir du studio.
Puis, bien sûr, essayer de travailler sur des choses
dont le contenu est important pour moi.
Et être capable de prendre plaisir au résultat final.
Et puis, j'ai trouvé une autre liste dans l'un de mes carnets qui contenait
toutes les choses que je pensais avoir apprises dans ma vie jusqu'à maintenant.
Et juste à ce moment-là, un magazine autrichien a appelé pour demander
si on voulait faire six doubles pages, concevoir six doubles pages
qui joueraient le rôle d'intercalaires entre les différentes rubriques du magazine.
Et tout le truc s'est emboîté naturellement.
Du coup, j'ai juste pris l'une des choses que je pensais avoir apprise -
dans ce cas, "tout ce que je fais me revient toujours" -
et on a fait ces pages à partir de ça.
Donc ça donnait : Tout
ce que
je fais
me
revient
toujours.
Il y a quelques semaines, une
(Rires)
entreprise française nous a demandé de créer cinq panneaux pour elle.
Là encore, on pouvait nous-mêmes décider du contenu.
J'ai donc simplement choisi une autre phrase.
C'était il y a deux semaines.
On a pris l'avion jusqu'en Arizona - le designer qui travaille avec moi et moi-même -
et on a photographié celui-ci.
Ca donne : Essayer
d'avoir l'air
cool
m'empêche
de vivre pleinement.
Et puis, on en a encore fait un.
C'est, à nouveau, pour un magazine, pour séparer les rubriques.
Ca donne : Avoir
C'est la même chose -
c'est juste photographié de côté.
Ca, c'est de face.
Puis : "du culot"
Là encore, c'est la même chose - "du culot" est juste au même endroit, c'est retravaillé.
Puis : "marche
toujours"
Puis "pour", avec la lumière allumée
(Rires)
Et "moi".
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)